>>> AT SOUTHWEST AIRLINES, WE
PRIDE OURSELVES ON A SMOOTH
FLYING EXPERIENCE.
>> OVER THE HOLIDAY SEASON, WE
MESSED UP.
OUR SYSTEM COLLAPSED, AND
THOUSANDS OF FLYERS WERE LEFT
STRANDED, AND YOU UNDERSTANDABLY
SCREAMED AT US FOR DAYS ON END,
EVEN MORE THAN YOU USUALLY DO.
>> AND SURE, WE LOST
$800 MILLION IN REV KNEW AND ARE
BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE FAA.
>> FOR STARTERS, WE ARE FINALLY
UPGRADING OUR ENTIRE COMPUTER
SYSTEM TO 2008 DELL COMPUTERS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE ARE SAYING GOOD-BYE TO THOSE
IBM THINKPAD LAPTOPS WITH THE
LITTLE RED NIPPLE IN THE MIDDLE.
>> NO MORE MISSING BAGGAGE AT
BAGGAGE CLAIM, GUARANTEED.
>> FROM HERE ON OUT, ALL LUGGAGE
WILL BE SORTED BY COLOR.
>> THAT MAKES IT YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY, NOT OURS.
>> SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO DALLAS,
BRING A RED SUITCASE.
>> BLUE BAGS GO TO CHARLOTTE.
>> AND GET TO THE AIRPORT EARLY
TO ENJOY OUR NEW PREMIER LOUNGE
LOCATED INSIDE STARBUCKS.
WE HOLD DOWN TWO OR THREE TABLES
FOR Y'ALL.
>> WE'RE MODERNIZING OUR AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL NETWORK.
>> WE WILL BE USING OUR OLD IBM
THINKPAD LAPTOPS WITH THE LITTLE
RED NIPPLE IN THE MIDDLE.
>> NOW I GET A PROPER FLIGHT
SCHEDULE INSTEAD OF FINDING OUT
WHERE I'M GOING 15 MINUTES
BEFORE TAKEOFF.
>> AND NOW WE'RE STREAMLINING
CHECK IN BY NOT HAVING ONE AT
ALL.
>> TRYING TO FILL UP THE PLANE
AND GO.
>> YOU GOOD.
>> WE'RE ALSO UPGRADING OUR
INFLIGHT STAFF STRICTLY WITH
PEOPLE WHO USED TO WORK AT
WAFFLE HOUSE.
COME AT THEM IF YOU WANT, BUT
THESE BIG PITCHES DON'T PLAY.
>> THAT'S ON US.
MOSTLY.
SOME OF IT'S ON YOU.
>> YOU BOUGHT THE TICKET.
>> AGAIN, YOU BOUGHT A SOUTHWEST
TICKET.
YOU OBVIOUSLY DON'T RESPECT
YOURSELF, SO WHY SHOULD WE?
>> THANK YOU.
>> FOR FLYING SOUTHWEST.
>> WELCOME ABOARD.
>> SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
IF IT'S THAT IMPORTANT TO YOU,
JUST WALK.